care podcast special guests are here
they just dropped a joint album it's
only right big hit hit boy sir what's
the deal bro
um it's crazy because you and I have
done a bunch of interviews and we always
talk about when your Dad's getting home
all right and you're home man welcome
home brother all right for sure good
looking good luck I gotta say I've never
seen somebody any rapper ever come home
maybe boozy and just be just non-stop
dropping [__] like you came home on a
mission bro yeah yep overdue Mission man
we uh non-stop Mission uh how long were
you going eight or nine years yeah yeah
it's crazy you could probably tell me
when grinding my whole life ended up
coming out you're obviously you're in
the music video it's a moment uh the
hs87 album comes out
were you able to kind of like see like
the G-Unit remix of that song and all
that stuff when you were out or did that
all happen like what what at what point
in time did we was in New York when uh
we actually thought the song was our
song we was riding in New York and we
heard it we heard him we like what the
[__] like my [__]
you need to holler at you yeah no that
was a crazy moment because like like you
said I think a lot of people especially
on the East Coast had kind of like
go see what I'm saying you know you take
your life back for people who don't know
the last time he was on the show he had
a dinosaur mask on right right
you're gonna have to cut to that don't
forget his iPad
the iPad is a must go sit on the couch
um no but I I think a lot of a lot of
people who weren't hip to what y'all
were doing assumed that was like a G
Unit record
that was wild that was wild like I
remember we uh we was in New York like
you said we landed we heard that joint
and we actually pulled up on uh 50 and
chopped it with him that day and the
[__] was like showing love like he was
breaking down [__] versus knew who
everybody was on the song I had the
whole Squad out there in New York you
know what I mean so he I mean but then
it kind of just like
fast forward just kind of was like
[__] they low-key just snatched the
swag up they did for sure that's one of
my favorite I mean I was like the last
uh you know time [__] took G Unit
serious was like oh North swag so that's
actually not too far from the truth in
terms of a group I don't know if anybody
else literally is the truth that was the
last moment they had you know I mean
because they had even what was that
random dude that a kid kid was on it
right was that who's on it kid kid was
on that remix I think so one of the
random dude who ended up in junior yeah
I don't know he said that he said that
man you dropped you brought G Unit back
my [__] gave me a hug yeah you feel me
you're a real [__] you know what I'm
saying so
um what was did you guys plan this on
phone calls this whole like hey are you
telling him like yo son I got
I got these wraps ready or you do did
you come out with this a notebook full
of [__] man it's a noble trash bags yeah
a lot man you know a lot but you know we
was in contact the whole time though so
I was on the thing thinking we was
keeping in contact like he put me on his
last CD when the Surfers round one yeah
he started it off with a rat from prison
so I remember that I was just ill for
him to he owned nine out of ten songs on
this one you know man it's only right
um for you uh hit I know like how
important it is to have your dad home
man like it's dope too to kind of
you're having like your Renaissance I
feel like you're like in your like
95 96 97 Jordan years right now
for sure you're saying like you could
like dad comes home you got four albums
out with nas a Grammy for album of the
year like no I mean even just like it's
just crazy like when you just put stuff
in retrospect like working with Nas and
working with a mature rapper like you
know in a different age bracket than I
am or whatever the case is it just
prepared me for like recording big hit
like it was just like a layup soon as he
came in we just like he had a he had
like 100 songs and he only been on for
two I mean a month and a half a month
you guys recorded a hundred he's
recorded like a hundred songs yeah Jesus
not even exactly yeah that's crazy man
um are you pre are you free from uh like
paperwork are you finally like yeah I'm
mine on [__] they they held me like six
years over my time man you know
political prisoner type [__] right but
uh yeah I got some Millions coming from
them lawsuit oh nice so you're gonna
you're shooting uh is it the correctness
of the state and you know the judge all
the should the prosecutors
yeah they gave me the legal sentence
they knew it was illegal before they
gave it to me what was it for if you
don't mind me asking okay yeah a car
accident yeah yeah
I may or may not have hit a car in a
parking lot and it kept it moving
[Laughter]
we I've been in the position where I've
done it at least seven or eight times
when I was like 20 22 no insurance might
tap somebody you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah no this some [__] [__] just
trying to rob me you feel me I'm coming
from Humboldt County with like 100
pounds of a tree and this is on we
hitting red lights running [__]
shooting all kind of [__] and we crashed
and jumped out and ran but the other
people got hurt so they were saying that
you know basically the whole argument
was saying that I should have stopped
and assisted the people in the car who
were trying to rob you but there was no
no the other
people's trying to pull over but we
clipped them in the back and
they flipped over got hurt
because because for people who don't
know Humboldt County is like a wild
place like oh yeah it's like it's like
Narcos in the forest out there yeah that
too but it's a lawless land man I guess
it's short it's off the map you got a
lot of spots that's even off the grid
you don't you can't even Google them you
know they just Word of Mouth you can't
live in that Community unless you're
growing trees and all kind of [__] like
you're not welcome no for sure uh we had
burner on the show and he told us the
story like how he had to go up a
mountain to pick up like I think it was
like a box like 100 pounds or something
yeah and he was he was afraid uh you
know essentially something similar kind
of had happened
yeah he was just explaining how crazy it
is up there it's like they got their own
language just telling me how uh you was
like you had didn't know nobody you was
like talking to the homeless people yeah
yeah when I got out I was handed by
Humboldt County you know he's always
buying that Mexican pressed Brown [__]
and then that kush came about like [__]
it I gotta go up here I just went up
there with a pocket full of money
hanging out with the bombs and you know
the the homeless people and [__] they
point you in the right direction or what
no that was the man this [__] the
homeless people was the demand they were
saying I ended up you know that's how I
linked up with them we was just going
out hanging out just you know they was
hungry as [__] buying a fool like
everything he wanted I was buying oh
[__] gotta get some fun we're gonna get
some drink they used to be talking like
man go and get what you want and I'm
buying a food I just need some wig I got
some weight come on the back of the
stores like a river back there with
tents and they living oh yeah and back
at the bottom River and just a trail
Full Of Weeds plants you know what I'm
saying like what the [__] now the
homeless dudes they they're like growing
they're like growing they're growing
along the river Gorilla growing you know
what I'm saying but uh is it kind of
crazy for you to get out because I mean
obviously when you went in it was it was
legal it was it medically legal no hell
no it was medically I don't think it was
it might not it might have come on just
last eight nine years yeah yeah yeah it
was converting it but how crazy is it
now because like now you're out and this
[__] is like really just like yeah this
is the game is messed up you can't
really make no money off of it you know
what I'm saying this is [__] up
especially yeah because I you know
they're so with these dispensaries and
the taxes and like you know it's just
wild though cause like we just did this
event called uh Olympics with Gucci Mane
and burner and that [__] was like it's
like the wheat Olympics just in the
middle of downtown oh yeah like 10 years
yeah yeah yeah like 10 years ago if you
would have told me I'd be like hanging
out in downtown L.A and just there's
just an open drug market and there's
police at the door and like like what
the [__] is going on yeah and there's
still people somehow like incarcerated
in California for yeah for a week yeah
they do it up there too Reggae on the
River you don't say everybody come there
with a special trees they've done cloned
and special you know hybrids and [__]
showing off they they little [__] if you
come come up there and they go to the
dispensaries and they regulate the
clones and right you know that's the
thing get that main strain where they
don't nobody have it and try to keep
that strain and boom